أجنبي ،
قد تسأل نفسك لماذا
يدق هذا الرجل على جيتار عقد
لأنه ليس غيتارًا ، إنه جولة
تجول [
موسيقى]
ما هو الطبل اليدوي ،
لذا هذا ما يمكن أن نطلق عليه ما
هو ليس غيتارًا مع خلع الرقبة
نحن في الواقع  حصلنا على براءتي اختراع في هذا
بسبب الشكل وبسبب
التدعيم الداخلي للتصميم ، الأداة المساعدة
وتصميم الشيء الذي اخترناه
لسببين ، إنه
بالطبع مثير للذكريات ، إنه
شكل مقبول بالفعل في
مجتمع الموسيقى  صحيح ، لكن
النوبة العلوية والسفلية أكبر
حجمًا ويخلق
نغمات أقل هنا مما يبدو عليه بالفعل ،
لذا فهو ينسجم بالفعل مع
تعدد النغمات ،
لذا فإن الأشخاص الذين يعتقدون أنني سأقطع
رقبة جيتاري  لقد حصلت على
جولة سريعة لنفسي ، لا يجب عليك تغيير
كل التدعيمات لأن القيثارات لديها
الكثير من الدعامات في الداخل للتخفيف من شد
الأوتار على وجه الجيتار
[الموسيقى] مع
الشعور بالإيقاع في هوليوود أنا